reject nation
the hierarchy of power in the dceu
is about to change that's my tyrone
magnus intro how's it going guys
john here uh to cover a little bit of dc
related snyderverse news
if you haven't tuned in yet today you
haven't been following along the past
week or two
uh greg's out of town he'll be back on
friday so for now you're
stuck with me um but yeah there has been
some
interesting developments regarding the
snyder cut both its performance on hbo
max as well as just the continued
deluge of thoughts and opinions on
whether or not the snyder verse should
continue
and how and i thought we could dive into
a little bit of that today because
obviously if you again have been paying
attention to this channel uh we've been
doing a whole lot of
snyder cut coverage little plug time um
we have a whole playlist
of zack snyder's justice league
reactions to the actual film
itself obviously those are highlights
can only show a little bit of footage
here on youtube
just to get it visible at all so yeah
there's that and you can also come over
to our patreon we have a full
length watch along there all four hours
of this movie
but yeah i wanted to dive into this
because it seems as though this is a
situation that is
ever-growing and ever-changing and we
have
definitely not heard the last of it yet
first off let's start with this for the
weekend of march 28th is according to
bloomberg
uh downloads of the hbo max app rose 64
for the top increase as compared to a
bunch of other streaming services and if
you look at this graphic i have here on
screen i mean that's pretty
staggering like their percent of growth
is like stars is the closest behind them
and it's not even
half the amount of growth because that
was one of the biggest questions was is
the snyder cut gonna be as big of a draw
for hbo max as they had hoped for and at
least as of the ending weekend of march
28th
uh it seems as though it was certainly
something of a success but that's a
pretty big deal especially
being able to tie that to zack snyder's
justice league tie that to a four-hour
movie you know but yeah
that in and of itself seems like one of
the biggest
things to pay attention to just because
again i'm sure part of the reason they
chose to green light
the snyder cut in the first place uh to
go back and restore it
would have been to help increase their
hbo max traffic and that seems like
something that has definitely happened
so a t if you're listening but yeah we
have some interesting information and
speculation as to the future of the
snyder verse both in terms of
batfleck specifically as well as henry
cavill's superman and the justice league
overall
and it's funny because you know hbo max
is often looked at as the saving grace
potentially for the snyder verse
you already have this gcpd show and
development there which isn't
necessarily snyder vs link it seems like
that's going to be much more linked to
robert pattinson
but at the same time if i've learned
anything about this
whole ecosystem of major companies who
decide what happens with these movies
it's that they don't always seem as
linked and as simpatico as you would
think and so
you know you have rumors about att
wanting one thing versus wb wanting
another thing and all of it coming down
in some way to either hbo max or
theaters
and so this conversation is is far from
over
but let's dive further in here i've got
a few quotes pulled from a couple
different articles mostly from
geekocitymag
uh mikey sutton the scooper of all
scoopers
the source of all sources he says a few
things here i actually want to kind of
get into
mostly pertaining to the overall future
of zack snyder's justice league as that
pertains to a couple specific characters
starting with batman he says here hbo
max continues to want ben affleck as
their dark knight
and as he's reported numerous times hbo
max wants to keep the snyder verse
intact and hopefully have new projects
coming down the line from zack snyder
himself which is certainly an exciting
prospect and one that seems more doable
than ever in the age of the multiverse
however there's also
further speculation here that they will
simply ignore the continuity of the
snyder verse and make no references to
them at all when wonder woman or aquaman
meet batman he will not be affleck
he never existed the dark knight is
robert pattinson
is sort of what it's purported that they
want and the way that they seem to want
to achieve that at least on the wb side
again
reportedly is that uh they want to have
batman essentially play the role that
supergirl
and or the flash would play in a
flashpoint scenario basically being the
martyr that helps save humanity thus
giving ben affleck his proper
send-off um but at the same time there's
speculation that that doesn't
necessarily spell the end for
bat flak entirely sutton goes on to
speculate here that what you could wind
up seeing is something more akin to
black widow where it's like yes
spoilers that character in the present
continuity may be
dispatched dead etc but we're still
going into their past and looking at a
different
significant moment there which you could
easily do with batman batfleck etc
especially again in a multiversal
scenario and that's fascinating to me
because you know you have them talking
about wanting to give pocket universes
to people like jj abrams
and other people within this and you got
your arrowverse on tv
and yet they want to draw the line at a
certain corner of the multiverse like
that's
the tricky thing about this all is that
multiverse opens you up to every
possibility so at what point do you
start drawing lines and being like well
this is definitely not going to be part
of the multiverse i guess you draw that
line at your purse strings but still
so how does this all get fixed well like
i said before i think this fight
is is long from over and today we've had
just a couple of
uh developments that would certainly uh
support that idea i mean it's been said
in the past
again by mikey sutton one of the other
uh
executive officers over at warner media
was really pleased with the snyder cut
and wants to see more so there's already
that happening behind the scenes uh but
in addition
you now have the inclusion of dwayne
johnson into the conversation with his
announcement today
uh that again the hierarchy of power in
the dc universe is about to change
and obviously i mean black adam very
powerful character his movie's coming up
but what i'm reading here is that dwayne
johnson has a huge amount of control and
say over the black adam movie which is
pretty consistent
with what i've heard about pretty much
any dwayne johnson project at this point
and it does seem like if
anyone could be attached to one of these
dc
films with enough sway and clout to
really call some shots
it's probably dwayne johnson and so
diving into that what mikey sutton says
here is that the rock
black adam himself truly wants a
connected dc movie universe and has been
a big backer of henry cavill
wb uh placed the misfiring of the dcu
partly on cavel as his superman didn't
do the box office numbers like he should
have
especially in comparison with what kevin
feige has done with iron man etc
um but he's been told that cavill is in
talks to return a shazam
in super is superman in shazam to that
not in a big role he goes on to say
discussions have been for superman to
fight dc's captain marvel in an epic
scene that finds the kryptonian under
the control of mr mind potentially
and there's also talk that in one of the
black adams sequels dwayne johnson would
like to have
not just the justice i mean the justice
society is already supposed to show up
in black adam but it seems like he wants
the entire
zack snyder justice league to show up in
future
installments of black adam so that is
something again
that that could be hugely significant to
this he goes on to say this would lead
to a justice league justice society
team up as they often did annually in
the comic books and from what he's been
told
the rock has full creative control over
his black adam movies and wasn't
pleased with the news of the snyder vs
demise he can override the executives as
a t
would take the rock side about using the
snyder verse one
source added to this the massive success
of the snyder cut has a t parent company
of order media seeking sequels and
spin-offs
and see that's the thing man i mean you
already have the fan generated movement
you have
restore the snyder verse trending all
weekend
and into the following week stuff trends
on a cycle that is pretty
fast these days and not a lot of stuff
lingers and the snyder cut
the snyder verse all that stuff has been
galvanizing especially twitter
since the movie dropped in before and if
this is to be believed you have further
support coming from
within and it's like it's one thing if
there are a couple wb execs who are into
it as well
but if you now have one of your key
creatives who seems to be a cornerstone
of your near
future throwing his lot in with the
snyder verse
i don't know what the outcome of all
this is i don't have like a major
prediction of like i know
it's like with spider-man and and marvel
and sony that seemed like
okay this is gonna get worked out
because they've already got their foot
in the door
and this is a little bit different
because they have had their foot in the
door they got their foot
out the door and then back in the door
and then we're
told to leave basically is what it feels
like with the response from wb being
like yeah it's done
we don't want to do any more of this um
i don't know what to make of this but i
have
a sneaking suspicion that it's
definitely not the last we've heard of
this night of verse i don't know if
we'll see justice league two or anything
like that but again you've got joe
mangianello out there
showing what his uh role would have been
in the batman being teased at the end of
jack snyder's justice league there's so
much flying around right now and again
if you have dwayne
johnson in your corner like that
it's like goliath it's like literally
like if you had zack snyder's
justice league and everybody involved
with that as the sort of underdogs going
up against the big studio
now they got somebody who's like the
king of hollywood right now on their
side and that seems like it could be a
hugely significant turning
point there's been speculation for a
long time that henry cavill
is supposed to return in shazam 2
specifically but also just that he has
a few pictures left in his deal or
recently instated into his deal
and whatnot and i mean this seems like
it could be the perfect way to marry
things together because at this point
you know
i mean bad continuity and uh
confusing installments in a lineage
you know like that's not new for comic
book movies necessarily and i think it's
interesting that with this speculation
you have people talking about you okay
you got your multiverse on tv and you
got your movie universe over here
and there's going to be no mention of
the snyder verse ever again anymore
even though half the characters are
still going to be from there and they're
just gonna pretend like
there was never a ben affleck batman
like you can do that as a means of
cleaning things up but at the same time
again with as much
traction as the snyder cut has shown
itself to have with as much
fan passion with as much passion from
creatives and stuff behind the scenes
reportedly
i have to imagine combined with the huge
success for just
hbo max's bottom line that yeah this is
not
the last by any stretch that we've heard
of the snyder verse so uh yeah leave me
your thoughts down below what do you
guys think of this i mean
are you full-on expecting just a fully
restored snyder verse are you expecting
maybe
some kind of hbo max specific
continuation that exists in its own
pocket universe
it seems like it's all on the table
right now so leave me your thoughts we'd
love to hear from you and
yeah i'll catch you on the next one much
love thank you for joining me if you
join me and i'll uh
yeah cheers